for jonathan chan the pictures in the
tenement museum bring back vivid
memories in 1989 he was a member of the
Student Union and witnessed the june
fourth massacre on tanaman square chen
says he owes it to his friends from back
then to not let the events be forgotten
when they realized reaffirm the Hong
Kong I was saying to say always set the
same stuff code how to the work go tell
the people on come on songs so I had to
talk about this then then the
opportunity I wise to keep the memories
to our life yes activists from Hong Kong
created this museum as a place for
remembrance they managed to complete the
project in spite of difficulties all
forms of commemoration are forbidden in
mainland China that's why the museum
caters especially to visitors from there
for Chinese from the mainland a visit
here is taboo no one wants to speak in
front of a camera especially younger
generation will say oh it's a shock to
me that I don't know this happened for
some of the older generation or this we
have not really seen for already 25
years and it refresh our memory and we
hope that they will go back to China to
spread what they have seen in Hong Kong
inside China so that people would know
the historical truth and will want to
you know demand for justice
jonathan chan also wants justice he
believes the death of his comrades
changed china forever chan says the
massacre revealed the communist regimes
true face and drove a wedge between the
people and the government but he refuses
to give up hope that the dream people
fought for 25 years ago will one day
come true